you know you sit down you try to do a
[__] podcast you buy all the gadgets
you get all the [__] widgets you get
everything all [__] whatever and what
what happens what happens there's still
a [__] problem
still a [__] problem you know but you
know if it wasn't for this technology I
couldn't sit here talking to you
you know
way out in mainland China
out on the Prairies in in in uh [__]
Kansas
you know back in the day I bet it was by
the way this is the Monday Morning
podcast for Monday April 24th 2023 this
is what it's supposed to be provided my
[__] cell phone doesn't crap out like
my [__]
I mean I just don't understand like how
much how much how much more [__] do I
have to buy I got a little camera on top
I got the [__] screen I got a mouse I
have a keyboard I have a little [__]
uh little housing what's over there an
interface
right I have headphones
I mean everything indicating that I
could record something
I have I have I have the internet
I could then upload it onto a site that
my [__]
producer could then take it from that
and put it wherever the [__] it goes
that you guys I have all that [__] I
have it all sitting right here
yeah there I sit
um
I mean I just why don't I just record it
on the [__] cell phone I mean what is
what is the point
I wake up I'm in a good mood wake up
little baby wake up right I'm in a good
[__] mood and I come out here and I'm
just everything goes to [__]
you know a lot of stuff breaking down
lately
for me you know my body [__] up my
shoulder again I'm finally just saying
[__] it
I'm gonna get an MRI I'm going to this
doctor
[__] Joe Rogan told me to go to like
seven years ago it was Ghost dude he'll
just still spin your blood and [__]
you know uh you know stem cell it or
whatever and you're gonna be like Lee
Majors and the Six Million Dollar Man
and I'm like oh you know okay
I'm gonna try to do it the old school
way for six [__] year I'm finally
done I'm finally done I'm not I'm not
starting back again doing the arm crawls
up the wall and then I I graduate to a
can of [__] tuna and then and I can
hold the weight of my arm oh boy isn't
this exciting can I get a little more
let me grab that ah and then go back to
the beginning again I'm done I'm [__]
done with it all right
I'm gonna be like that cutie pie that uh
ran track with the snaggletooth there
you know and everybody's like oh my God
you want everything and then she's like
well not really
then everybody got [__] all upset
with her
but were they really upset with her or
was she really just something that they
could take the frustration of her own of
your own life out on
I never understood why people got that
upset
well you know I understand being
disappointed but the level of upset that
they got with that woman I just thought
it was like come on the whole [__]
sport is filthy
the whole sport is filthy they're all
filthy
um and you know why because when you go
all natural you end up like me
it's [__]
your body breaks down
um so I'm gonna be buying it BB
getting both my shoulders done I got a
[__] MRI coming up
you know which to this day you know it's
a I still don't understand why that
thing is that [__] loud
um
Dean Del Rey's got a great bit on how
[__] loud it is I mean it's unreal
it's like it's like your head is inside
a garbage truck
um
all right so anyway plowing ahead here
oh speaking of things breaking down so I
got my car fixed I had a problem with
the uh the driver's side window the
engine's fantastic all right she's a
goddamn [__] I've almost had that
car I've almost had that car seven years
you know
I'm not like these these flippers out
here that lease cars and every two years
they get something new
you know I stick with [__] I see
something I like I get it I'm like that
I'm like that with cars I'm like that
with broads
you know and I'm like that with that
Patriots helmet
that I got in the early 1970s for
Christmas and there it sits never fit my
head my head was too big for it back
then certainly not going to fit now but
you know what God damn it
I [__] uh I still have it
even though my brother broke it
you know used to always break all my
[__] toys so he broke that thing and
then uh
he broke that thing when he was in his
20s too like well beyond the time that
he should have been still breaking my
toys but he did and then I uh I I ended
up ordering a new face mask it's not the
original face mask but it looks [__]
great I've had that forever
you know I get [__] I like it and I stay
with it that's what I am you know so
anyway my car uh my car's windows are
like my shoulders
once I get one fixed the other one gets
[__] up so I get my I get my car
repaired and I'm I'm old school I take
it to the dealership
I I pay right through the warranties you
know ended after five years so now I'm
paying through the [__] notes I go to
the dealership they charge you three
times as much but you know what it's
Jaguar parts I can't confirm that but
I'm gonna say it is I'm sorry Jaguar
however the [__] Jaguar
Jack wow sorry I watched too many Bruce
Lee movies growing up Jaguar
um so you know the automatic window
thing sure you do you know you just
click it once and it goes right
well mine would go all the way up and
then come back down again so I bring it
up and go away
I was like that's odd let me try that
again
so I'm like really so then I'm like out
and about in public and you know I live
in LA you can't leave your [__]
window down you come back there'll be a
homeless family in there you know one of
them's a veteran who used to get cheered
half time at football games but now the
country's done with them and he's under
an overpass and all those same people
that cheer him now scream at him to get
a [__] job right when they're at a
red light
so I don't want that I don't want to
deal with that right
this is capitalism it's every man for
himself
so what I had to do was I had to have
the I'd shut the car off
you know but the the battery will still
stay on if you want to sit in the car
for a few minutes but the second you
open the door the battery cuts off so
that's what I had to use so I'd shut the
car off and then I'd go
zip and then [__] try to time it
where I open the door but a couple times
I open it too late and still go oh whoa
and I'd be like [__] and I've turned my
car back on
people at the grocery store looking at
me
anyway
so I finally get it fixed dealt with
that for like three weeks where I
finally got a window where I could get
it over there I get it fixed right I go
and I uh I do a podcast interview with a
huge [__] guest that uh I'm not gonna
name yet
um but it's [__] huge let me tell you
something's [__] huge so uh I go over
there I interviewed this person he was
Beyond Beyond
anything just just interviewing him was
going to be amazing and then he turned
out to be at the greatest guy ever right
it's not driving away and I'm like you
know what I'm gonna go fly let's add the
day I'm gonna go fly
go fly around zip around on a helicopter
right why not I flunked everything in
math I have no business leading this
life you know
so why not continue leading that doesn't
make sense right so I get on the 405 and
it's just jammed you know as they said
in The Californians it was jammed and by
the time I got up to Sunset I'm like I'm
not gonna have [__] time to
pre-flight it get in the thing zip
around and then pick my daughter up from
school so I said [__] it I made a right
turn
on the sunset I stopped off at a cigar
bar
and I was like am I am is that [__] it I
haven't had one in over two weeks so I
pull in I go down there
um
the same regulars are in there right and
I come in you know making your way in
the world today right say hello
everybody I sit down they got a new
cigaro so [__] smooth
I enjoy it I had water I stayed away
from the soda
everything's going great I go back
upstairs I get in my car I tip the guy
at the [__] thing you know
how much is it here's another one for
you right
old [__] Billy good times I get in
the car
it's hot as balls I go to put down both
windows driver's side comes down no
problem passenger side isn't moving but
I'm hearing some noise in the door and I
was like that's odd
let me try it again I thought the lock
was on I tried all of this [__] nothing
worked and I finally tried again and I
heard something go down
inside the door nothing happened and
then like it was like a half a second
pause and the whole window just goes it
just [__] dropped out
it just dropped down
and then landed on an angle so like the
back corner was sticking up like a
[__] glass shark fin
and you know what I did you know what I
did
I burst it out laughing
different for me I didn't flip out I
just started laughing because like it
just sometimes it just gets to the point
of like what the [__] can you do right
so I just I just left
I laughed and I was like all right well
I guess I gotta [__] deal with this
so now my car
uh Jackie as she's known
um I told you I gave her that name when
my wife was jealous when I got the car
like you know playful jealous
because she was when the thing showed up
and it was that that [__] British
racing green I had the sick rims you
know more Rim than Tire just a total
badass [__] vehicle
and you open the door and it lights up
and says Jaguar down on the thing like
you're walking into a nightclub I mean
this was some sexy [__] in October 2016.
I know that's all pedestrian now I'm
sure a [__] Prius looks like that now
but in 2016 this was the hot [__] as the
kids say and she was just like I didn't
I didn't know you could order a car
I'm like yeah she goes I just walked on
the lot and bought one like a jackass
so I started acting like I was more into
the car than I was her so of course I
had to give it a name and I was just
like listen I go you can't raise your
voice in the car Jackie likes a nice
you know quiet ride and she would just
you know give she knew I was [__]
around with her obviously so anyways
um
but it's funny my kids call the car
Jackie
you know so this morning
the car was in the shop and my
daughter's like going she's going dad
where's Jackie I want to ride to school
and Jackie
like
she's uh yeah she's uh she's getting
fixed again and Jackie's having some
problems
so um you know but it's the second time
I've had a [__] issue this quickly so
I I laughed at it first
and then I got annoyed
and my wife was like do you need to like
is this like a lemon law thing I'm like
it's just the windows I don't know I
don't the engine's fine
it's fine I'm driving this [__] thing
forever and then I just started thinking
like wait a minute everybody else trades
their cars in every couple of years I'm
I've had this thing six almost seven
years
right
so then I was like [__] this [__] I just
I don't know how I just started looking
around and next thing you know within
five minutes I'm on the internet I was
looking at a a BMW M5 stick shift
and I'm like that's what I'm gonna get
then I'll be happy
and all I could think of was driving
that the car was so [__] expensive
it's like where would you take it
could he go down to the grocery store
[__] get down there
then anybody who parks near you you just
have to be like oh
[Laughter]
every time you valet
that's what I don't understand about
those cars like every time I see like a
Ferrari
which really is the car if you ask me
the car you want to get I feel
out here in La if you survive this
business you don't go crazy you keep
your money
you know you don't buy into any of the
[__] so you don't become an arrogant
ass [__] [__] you know which
probably failing on that but you know in
the end
you know when you made your money and no
matter what they do to you you're still
going to be all right
you know your Beard's all white
you got that leather Malibu Tan
you know your wife's got some fake tits
and teeth is white as Eric Estrada
that's when you go out and you buy the
Ferrari California that's the car
that's the car all of those other
Ferraris if you're not on your way to
the track it's the stupidest thing ever
but the Ferrari California is the GT GT
standing for Grand Touring
I looked that up a long time ago GT is
basically okay this is the race car but
you're gonna drive it down the street so
we're going to make it nicer more plush
heavier but you're still going to have a
nice fast car that's the [__] car I
think oh is that what you think Bill
guess what I think nobody gives a [__]
oh come on
there's no reason to be like that
you know what I did this week and I was
all proud of myself
um
I memorized
everybody in MotoGP their numbers
their teammates and all I have to do is
just get the teams down because I used
to know that a couple of years ago and
then uh I got all busy and I missed a
season and I came back and [__]
Ducati for some reason now has light
blue motorcycles they still have the red
ones the factory team
but even then it's not the same red a
lot of [__] changed people change teams
and all of that type of stuff and uh I
had I had to go back and get caught up
so I did that
and you know because I still have the
program
from the Circuit of the Americas
and um
I was just thumbing through this I just
think that like this is the coolest
[__] sport
as far as racing goes so I I
memorized all of these and then I wanted
my wife to quiz me and she just laughed
at me and just was like I'm not doing
that
it's like yeah I memorized all the names
all their numbers and then their
teammates uh you want to see me do it
and she's like why would you do that
it's like I don't because I like it
laughs
so that's what happens you know when
when you do that to your wife where you
sometimes you're just a dick to be a
dick she ends up doing it back to you
but it ends up being funny so
um I'm looking forward they have their
next race I want to say is in Spain
I don't know if it's Madrid or whatever
I have the app on my phone like I'm
[__] All In
um
so I cannot wait for that I'm still
buzzing
off of uh taking that Ducati around the
track but what has happened fortunately
is I've calmed the [__] down as far as
like
getting back to you can't ride a
motorcycle in California
or anywhere other than a track it's too
[__] dangerous with everybody texting
and everyone's on like a [__] pot
cookie now
which I'm not saying that's necessarily
oh it is if you're driving I guess
um
but anyway let's talk some sports here
this is when all the ladies fast forward
the Bruins beat the Florida Panthers uh
like I said they would in game three
everybody got worried about game two and
I said no man they're gonna come out and
they're going to kick the [__] out of
them they're gonna [__] score like
five goals I was close they scored four
but then they let in two at the end of
the game I did not like that I did not
like that at all I was like we had them
on the [__] ropes and we just gave
them hope if we shut them out for
nothing that's the difference between a
series going five games and going six
games but little did I know that the the
Bruins
mine is Patrice Bergeron and David crazy
we're gonna come out and uh they were
going to win game uh game four also and
take a three to one lead how about
Charlie McAvoy huh all of a sudden
becoming this physical Force stepping up
clean hits letting people know they got
to have their [__] heads up if
they're going to come into our Zone
um he's had some great open Ice hits
I've watched as much as I as I could
with the kids and this was a Super Mario
weekend we went to Universal we went on
the ride we saw the movie the whole
[__] thing
um
you know it was my daughter's spring
break so uh
me and the lovely Nia
we went over to Universal you know it's
[__] hilarious I told this song by
the way on the live podcast that I did
um by the way if you didn't see it I I
actually feel bad for you
um I [__] murdered I'm not gonna lie
to you I did like an hour and 15 50
minutes I'm half tempted to take the
tape and just send it to Netflix and be
like here's my next special
I don't know I was I was you know what
you know why it went so well because I
was nervous
I wasn't nervous I was going like how
the [__] am I gonna do 90 minutes by
myself
just like winging it
and
um
because I could do that just sitting
here because I get to live in
Fantasyland that you guys are all
laughing finding all of this interesting
but when you do it live well do it live
[__] it right when you do it live
you know exactly what's happening you
know whether or not you're killing or
not and if something's dying or whatever
and you know
if something dies on this I don't
[__] know I just keep plowing ahead
you know it's when you know you're in
front of a live audience and it's
something dies you know you almost you
got to address it but also blow it off
so it doesn't
[__] up your flow because if you just
start your flow will get blocked with
you thinking like oh my God it's not
going well they liked me a second ago
now they don't like is my career over
you know you just start catastrophizing
in your head and you're not going to be
funny
unless you just sit there and talk about
how much you're freaking out that you're
not doing well which would be funny for
about 20 to 25 seconds and then it's
just going to be a staring contest so I
went out there and um
you know uh we told people not to use
their phones or anything cigars of
course there's some [__] woman
sitting there filming the whole thing
I say something to her she doesn't put
her phone down she's just laughing
doesn't give a [__] and I went off on
her and then that just sort of opened
everything up and uh
I thought I was an hour and 10 minutes
in and I looked and I was actually an
hour and 45 in like that's how easy it
ended up being the uh Andrew demolis the
questions he got
was amazing and the Troubadour couldn't
have made it any easier and all the
people at moment crushed it with the way
it looked and all of that type of [__]
so
um thank you to everybody around the
world the world the world that that
watched it and thank you to everybody
that came out and showed up and bought
tickets
I had a great time so anyway
by the way you know something here's
somebody that everybody [__] hates if
you're a Bruins fan is uh
Matthew how do you say it is it Chuck
Matthew
um why is the T there nobody knows
because it's annoying just like he is
and that's why I love him
he's the best thing on that team and how
about at the end of game four
where that guy starts some [__]
not only gets his team on the power play
he gets our goaltender
to [__] drop the gloves and take his
mask off like he's gonna fight him and
then he gets two
right
he gets them on the power play and gets
our goaltender taken out of the [__]
game I mean I'm trying to Claude Lemieux
couldn't have done it any better
although Claudia would have done
something like career ending to the to
the [__] goaltender but like uh I
[__] love that guy
um Celtics are up three games to one
and uh I'll tell you who I love on the
Atlanta Hawks is that Trey Young
that kid is a [__] beast wants the
ball at the end of the game you're given
the ball at the end of the game and he
knocks the [__] shot down
I saw what game did we lose did we lose
game two we lost game three
we lost game three and um
like the Bruins I saw it down the
stretch so I I watched the Celtics
you know make a heroic effort to try to
win that game
and uh we hit a couple of threes and all
of that and he just kept [__]
answering
um
like that's a star that you could really
build a team around if the NBA was more
like the NFL but like I just feel like
that kid's gonna end up leaving
he'll be on the Lakers soon
you know those wine and [__]
this is my impression of every star
player
the star player on the Lakers sense
magic because I have no problem with the
magic ERA this is my impression I need
more free agents
I don't wanna lead a team that's too
hard get everybody else's best players
and have them come out here
and then we'll dunk on [__] people
coming off the bench and you know pose
in front of the camera like we're in Run
DMC
[__] NBA Stakes
they sold their soul
they sold their soul with that [__]
gangster who passed away who ran that
league and fixed games I'm convinced of
it
I'm [__] I'm not going to say his
name because he's dead and can't defend
himself like he would even respond to
this podcast Bill get out of your own
ego I'm just saying
like they what the Celtics and Lakers
did accidentally
which was basically draft and through
shrewd trades I've said this a million
times but I'll say it again
actually made two super teams
and they kept clashing in the finals and
the ratings went through the [__]
roof
through the [__] roof
you know you had the the
you know the two best players one was a
white guy one was a black guy it had it
was like boxing the Great White Hope all
of this [__] all of that [__]
you know
propaganda and promotion and they ended
up passing all of the sports
even football
like nobody ever thought baseball was
going to get past and in the 70s
football started getting better ratings
and then basketball in the late 70s
where it looked like it was going to go
out of it looked like it was going to go
under the league went from being
predominantly white in like 15 years to
be predominantly black and there was a
bunch of racists that didn't want to
watch it because of that and then there
was a massive you know the cocaine
problem and it was the 70s and doctors
were saying cocaine was no more
addictive than caffeine which is pretty
[__] addictive I'm finding and um
the league got a really bad reputation
um
for drugged up players which they did
have and then there was also like not
only they drugged up you know well I
can't do the southern accent because
everybody's racist not only they're
drugged up they're also black we don't
want to watch this blah blah blah that's
what happened and then Along came a guy
named Irvin Magic Johnson
and Larry Henderson bird sorry I don't
know his middle name
right
they came along
Magic Johnson
who just has the [__]
charisma
of a movie star ends up in Los Angeles
Larry Bird
just picture him at a wedding dancing
the whitest [__] guy ever and he's
twice the size of an average white guy
he's like a double cheeseburger a white
guy goes to Boston historically one of
the most racist [__] places ever
it was perfect
and then read our back and whoever the
[__] was that with the Lakers built
these teams around them
they already had actually they already
had Kareem
anyway and then they end up like having
this this massive
back and forth Ali versus Frazier from
like
84 85 86 87 80 it just kept [__]
going
in the meantime Jordan came in a league
and then the Pistons were coming up
right with their filthy brand of [__]
we can't really play basketball so we're
gonna beat you down to our talent level
horseshit that they [__] did oh did
you leave your feet I'm gonna take him
out from underneath you and act like you
know this is some sort of strategy
Beyond I'm just trying to hurt you and
end your career
anyway having said that
I did like Joe Dumars John Sally
and Isaiah Thomas Vinnie microwaved
Johnson I actually did like all of those
guys
um I even like my horn I just didn't
like lamb beer it's just like dude
you're just out there
cheating
someone leaves their feet and you and
you just take them out like anybody a
guy in a crowd could do that to you and
have you land on your [__] head
anyway they made all of this money
and then all of a sudden you know then
they went to Jordan and then Jordan
leaves and then they're like what the
[__] do we do now that's when I think
they started fixing games
that's why I think they started fixing
games and they just allowed then that
became their business model well in the
80s we made all of this money what was
it because because these two Juggernaut
teams were playing each other okay
that's our business model that's what
keeps us on top so we don't give a [__]
and that's why they allowed Durant to go
to [__] the Warriors I've said all
this [__] a million times before I don't
even know how I got off on that I'm like
seriously I know I do this all the time
it [__] kills me because I love
basketball I love the way it used to be
and everybody had a big man and a star
[__] point guard
and they just went at it
as opposed to all [__] hanging out
drinking Rose and piling on the same
[__] team
Oh Billy old man in the house
um
all right
with that my daughter drew me a picture
today
or yesterday oh no she actually made
this thing when I was coming back from
the road
it was one of those things where you
fold it and it has a picture and then
you open it it says something else
it said love in it and I save all those
things
someday when she gets older and she
moves out or marries gets married I'm
going to look at those and I'm going to
cry
until then I'm going to enjoy the ride
baby
um all right let's do the um
let's do the reads for this week uh
uh sorry if I'm babbling all right
because I I really
uh
I just did I already did a [__] hour
and 50 of talking to myself
by the way talking about that goddamn
Universal
my wife is like the king of getting the
VIP
We Are Forever walking around lines We
Are Forever sitting in lounges and all
that it costs an arm and a leg and I'm
always like what the [__] but then when
we get there I always look our guy you
were right you're right this is the way
to do it she goes yeah just let me
handle this [__]
so
Universal
the park it's like Delta Airlines where
you think you're in group one you are in
group one but 19 groups are going to
[__] board before you half the
[__] planes on you like what the [__]
so we got these VIP things
thinking that we were going to walk by
all these sad sacks standing in [__]
line and whatever VIP we didn't get VIP
extra special [__] you know missing a
limb VI whatever the [__] it was
Mother veteran mother missing a limb
[__] group
they were just like yeah this doesn't
apply to this ride they're like all
right well I guess we'll just stand in
line it was two hours in 40 [__]
minutes
dude there was kids crying
there was no water there was nothing and
they then you were like standing in the
sun then you go into the structure come
back out go back in come back out I mean
I don't even know what
I know what and it was like
when we were going back outside they'd
have these these big poles you know
holding the structure up and parents
were sending their kids to stand in the
shade while they went around the weaved
around the [__] line to come back
around again too it was
it was for a three minute ride
um
we walked out of that thing and the
whole time was sitting there and every
once in a while like 12 people would
just whisk by in this other
line and I'm just sitting there looking
like
um why the [__] didn't we get those
tickets
and
I was like well
if I say this
she's gonna get mad
because I'm gonna say she did something
wrong
and I didn't do anything to get this
thing going so I'm not gonna [__] say
and I finally after like an hour and 15
minutes I was just like when people walk
by I was like I was like what are those
tickets and she goes I know she goes I
thought that I had the VIP and I thought
that that would get us past this line
but they said it didn't count and we
this is a thing too we paid an extra
hundred bucks for these [__] tickets
so we would go around the line and we
showed up and go they're like yeah no
that doesn't count
you know you can do that on like the
[__] uh
which is a Eastwick ride you know some
ride that's like 20 years old you could
do like what you have works on that ride
but not the brand new [__] this is the
brand new Super Mario World which was
amazing by the way so long story short
um
we finally ended up getting in there
and uh
and we got on the ride and it was only
three minutes long and I was just
sitting there going like oh my God is
this like because like one of the kids
you know we went with this other dad he
brought his son and at one point the kid
was just like hanging over the rail
staring at the ground and he just goes
this is the most boring thing I've ever
done in my life and I was like oh my God
this is a [__] nightmare but we
finally we finally got on the ride
and we walked out
you know we went to The Simpsons part I
got a Krusty Burger and I just looked to
my wife and I was just like dude I am I
am wiped
all right and fortunately our daughter
was cool with leaving we bought like a
Super Mario t-shirt or some [__] and we
got in the car and we came home and I
was thinking like I mean the car ride
home was just quiet my daughter fell
asleep
me and my wife just had like a 600 yard
stare
um
and we end up getting back into like we
get to the house and uh
we get back
my daughter's grandmother my
mother-in-law was there and she was like
how was it
and my daughter just freaked out she
goes it was unbelievable so I was like
all right thank God
thank God right and there you go see you
learned something from kids you stand in
a two hour and 40 minute line but still
if you get to ride on the ride it's it's
unbelievable
then again they have young legs unlike
myself all right Butcher Block box
blocks butcher box everybody you know
eating out is fun but there's nothing
like cooking with butcher but yeah it's
way better
it's way better tastes better
you know it's cheaper
and you know nobody spit on your food
right with butcherbox you can easily
find high quality Meat and seafood you
can trust it's 100 grass-fed beef
free-range organic chicken pork raise
crate free and wild caught Seafood
humanely raised no antibiotics or added
hormones it gets delivered right to your
doorstep with free shipping always and
customized box plans
butcher Box gives you a variety of high
quality cuts and an amazing value within
with exclusive member deals recipe
inspirate
i-n-s-p-r-i-s-p-r-i-r-a-t-e in inspirate
it's underlined in Red so it's not
spelled correctly so this isn't me
guides tips and hacks what would that
Recipe Inspirations
installations
insulin get free chicken thighs for a
year
it sounds oddly perverted free chicken
thighs for a year and twenty dollars off
your first box when you sign up today
look at this thighs this box what are we
doing here that's a that's three three
pounds of bone-in chicken
thigh thighs free in every box for a
year plus twenty dollars off your first
order when you sign up at butcherbox.com
and use code Burr b-u-r-r claim this
deal at butcherbox.com
and use the code Burr all right we got
one more read here but before we do I'm
gonna take a little sippy here
um
water that's all you should be drinking
if you're trying to to lose weight you
should only be drinking water water with
lemon
make sure the lemon helps flush
everything out of your system as it eats
away the enamel of your teeth
all right oh look who it is everybody
it's Soul zip
screwed up
you know weather you're starting a new
business
or growing one
if you want it to be successful you need
the most talented people on your team
that's where
[Applause]
[Music]
Turk comes in and right now you can try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com why
should you let Zips yes
help you hire for your business well
because
[Music]
powerful matching technology finds high
quality candidates for a wide range of
roles got your eye on one or two people
who'd be perfect for your job well
sip
lets you send them a personal invite
you can slip into their DMS hey baby you
want to work over at this Subway so
you're more so they're more likely to
apply ZipRecruiter also offers
attention-grabbing labels that speak to
job flexibility like remote
training provided
urgent
and more to help you to help your job
stand out let's zip fill all your roles
with the right candidates four to five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
see for yourself go to this exclusive
web address that's it for free
ziprecruiter.com
that zip
dot com slash bird zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
oh look who it is everybody everybody's
everybody loves this guy everybody loves
this guy and I don't know what he does
other than just smile with his eyes
while wearing a bathrobe a pullover
bathrobe it's the Dalai Lama everybody
you know
something about him it's got that cop
haircut does he have a flat top my nuts
does he got to pull back like Steven
Seagal minus the ponytail I just picture
he's always smiling with his eyes he has
on like Santa Claus glasses
and then he has uh he the he he has on
like a karate ghee but it's a pullover
so now you know he's not going to kick
you you know
that's the thing anytime somebody has on
a bathrobe there's always that part of
you where you're trying to see if they
have on pajama pants they have on pajama
pants give them pajama pants you're not
gonna try to kick me if your pants match
your robe okay I'm taking a step back
but it's also he's always sitting on his
knees
he's just a chill dude
right
hey Billy red balls
uh want to know your thoughts on the
Dalai Lama asking the kid to suck on his
tongue
what on video after kissing him on the
mouth
want to know my thoughts on that yeah I
don't want to look at that uh we have
proper authorities that look into stuff
like that and for whatever reason they
were they're such good people that they
actually do something about people like
that if that's what he's doing and they
watch stuff like that
they then gather the evidence and then
they have to go get this person but me
fortunately I don't have to like just
picturing that
anyways thanks for all the podcasts and
great stand up please come to Dallas and
go [__] yourself well there goes my home
I just like [__]
I just I just I'm Bill Burr and I
approve of this Dalai Lama is his name
Dolly mom he's the Dalai Lama
all right hang on a second now I gotta
look this [__] up
I'm just gonna look up the Dalai Lama
and see what we see what it says here
the
Dale Lama
uh his Holiness the Dalai Lama brief
biography his holiness
China's reincarnation Monopoly has a
Mongolia problem
Dalai Lama's abusive Behavior nothing
new
indo-tibetan groups come out in support
of The Dalai Lama
the Dalai Lama on Twitter
all right well they've done a pretty
good job scrubbing it off the front of
the thing all right abusive Behavior
the Dalai Lama is under Fire in the
media after video was shared of his
inappropriate interaction with the child
many people around the world were
shocked to see this Disturbing Behavior
coming from someone who was Often touted
by Western media as a holy man or even a
social justice leader
oh God can any of them just be good
people
anytime any one of these [__] people
more times than not but this morally
questionable Behavior comes as no shock
to anyone familiar with the Dalai Lama's
corrupt and deceptive history whoa that
just took
who says this
is one of these website this is
workers.org including his having
enslaved thousands of people before the
Revolutionary overthrow of feudalism by
Tibetan people and his subsequent years
as an operative for a U.S backed regime
changed while on the CIA payroll
what
Tibet has been politically merged with
other parts of China now the People's
Republic of China for hundreds of years
in some form or another having been
officially Incorporated with China since
at least the 1720s under the The Zing
Dynasty Queen Dynasty
there was a brief period after the fall
of the zingwing Dynasty when Tibet was
recognized internationally as part of
the Republic of China but local Tibetans
what the [__] happened with the Dalai
Lama [__] I don't know
all I can tell you is that story is why
I don't go to church all right
you wait till Joel Osteen goes down I've
been calling him Joel Olsteen
you guys never corrected me and maybe
thought I was just deliberately saying
his name wrong but I thought there was
an L in there
Joel Osteen uh the good news about salt
okay hey Billy bold body I really admire
all your efforts to stay healthy
I like how you you acknowledge that I'm
not healthy but my effort you're trying
bill
I wanted to share with you some
information about Himalayan salt years
ago in your podcast you read an email
about pink salt and its benefits over
common table salt the benefits include
improve respiratory diseases balance
your body's pH reduce signs of aging
improve Sleep Quality regulate blood
sugar increase libido great news right
well as it turns out there's is small
amounts of lead in the common pink salt
just just
distributed Jesus Christ
I don't think I was ever going to get
through that word distributed at stores
I don't think I've ever seen that
written
distributed
d-i-s-t-r-i-b-u-t-e-d can you use it in
a sentence I can't even say it uh bad
news right maybe not because the amount
of lead is below the minimum allowance
good news right I'm not sure either
enjoy your day love the podcast
I know right what do you do with that
it's just every every type of food
there's the people that sell it saying
it's good and then the people that are
selling something else and then they
just trash it
she's a good girl she'd make a great
wife and a mother she's a [__] I know
12 guys she banged last weekend
I don't know what to do with that
um
whatever I mean who gives a [__] you're
gonna die just whatever color salt you
want have a good time with it you know
I'll tell you some of the behemoths I
saw walking around that theme park the
fact that they were still alive I know
I'm doing pretty good but that also
doesn't mean anything I know some skinny
people that have just [__] dropped
the heart attacks
oh it's a crazy world Mad World all
right umbrella girls
hey hey biker Billy oh Jesus I know
you're going to talk about well how do
these still exist because nobody's
watching MotoGP I bet it's too many
MotoGP races such a great time I work
for one of the beer sponsors and got to
hang out on the paddock and in the
broadcast Booth Etc that's [__] cool
my question is for for you was why don't
they have umbrella girls for other
sports like Golf and swimming maybe more
people would watch these boring ass
Sports I'd like
to something an umbrella girl in the on
Deck circle of an MLB game would make
the games way more fun to watch glad you
had fun in Austin and took huge balls to
ride on the track with those Maniac fans
go finger yourself uh Jesus
um
what are we saying here what was the
question I don't know what the [__]
question was oh MLB is what I was going
to talk about you know MLB games are
down to on average 2 hours and 38
minutes the pitchers on the pitch clock
now everybody they keeping it moving
it's so smart it moves right along I
[__] love baseball I don't need any
umbrella girls
um
but like I think just like car racing
motorcycle racing and he's the sort of
racing is always synonymous with
beautiful women
you know if there's a if there's money
around and there's a beautiful car there
you're not gonna have to look too far to
find an absolutely stunning woman it's
just it is part of the world and there's
certain women that don't like that stuff
and they're called ugly
uh
sorry it was an easy joke I went for it
what do you want from me I'm doing back
to back [__] podcasts here doing my
own [__] Jerry Lewis Telethon a
podcast here podcasting here
by the way uh parents out there I highly
recommend the new Super Mario movie it's
great
it's great Chris Pratt Pratt uh [__]
uh Charlie Day
Sebastian does a voice I knew it was him
uh
um who else who else I don't know
it's it's
the movies it was just really done right
it's one of those things where it was
great for the kids also entertaining you
know our daughter sat between us and
like you know there's a bunch of jokes
in there for adults and I would look at
Nia and we will start cracking up and
then afterwards guess what we went I
haven't been there since the 2000s
my wife goes hey let's go to The
Cheesecake Factory
and I was like Nia you know I hate that
place I haven't been in that place
I think in 15 years
she goes I know but it's like
it's right next door but blah blah blah
so it's just like all right [__] it
and I went in there I actually had their
uh their beat and and avocado salad off
the Skitty menu
you know it was good of course they
brought bread and butter to the table
and I ate a [__] loaf myself but I
did get the [__]
you know I don't know but it was the
[__] show that I remember I do remember
what was amazing too was the level that
entire families are on their phones
because I'm totally addicted to my phone
and uh Nia told me like five times come
on but what do we say no phones at the
table and I kept going you're right
you're right and I would put it down I
would shut it off and I would find
myself subconsciously picking it up
turning it back on to play this this
word game that I have on the phone
and uh I was just like Jesus I really
got a problem and then
I looked over and there was this family
right
I think they were Daughters of friends
and they were like in their teens and
they were literally eating while holding
their phones
looking at them kind of like the way uh
back in the day you'd read the
newspapers you ate your coffee you ate
your coffee you know drank your coffee
and had your eggs
but what blew me away was the parent
that was with them the adult was also on
her phone
and when I got to go to the bathroom she
was like playing some game
and uh they weren't saying anything that
each other and at one point they did
take a selfie together
and uh
I was saying to Neo go too look at that
family I mean you think I'm addicted you
know you know that is I don't have a
drinking problem look at that [__]
person
and she goes yeah everybody's like that
she goes and she could you know we sit
in a booth she was across from me she
could see this other family she goes
there's a whole family watching Coco
melon
on a laptop which is a kids show
and as we walked out I saw that family
they were all watching it and the dad
was asleep
hahaha
dad just nodding out
I'm not gonna lie to you there was a
point though I thought I was going to
fall asleep
when we were watching Super Mario and
I'm like wow that would be like the most
dad thing ever
is to [__] go go to go to a kids
movie and like the lights go down you're
like oh my God this chair is so
comfortable
it was the IMAX you know so we had like
the [__] thing that lifts your legs
up
I mean they did everything but give you
a [__] little shoulder rub I was
almost I it was a couple times I like
nodded and came back I'm like can't be
that guy
I can't have my daughter being like Dad
you're missing the best part all right
best pickup line that changed my life
all right here we go
hey skinny Bill young lady
I love when the lady's right in young
lady listener here chiming in on my best
pickup line that changed my life
story time I like how she's breaking
this down Story Time colon I was 19 in
my sophomore year at college and finals
week was approaching as any horny
stressed out teen I wanted to get laid I
met this guy at a Halloween party and we
exchanged Snapchat info
corny I know not even my actual number
that's corny that sounds like [__]
Buck Rogers to me which was a space show
in the late 70s if you're the person
listening to this who wrote this
um
I was about to be like oh is that how
the kids do it now
but she goes but it never went anywhere
I was studying with my friend at the
time trying to figure out how to get
laid in a short amount of time doesn't
it blow your mind that women think this
way they really made us think like they
were like ooh gross get away from me and
you're like why come on touch it and
they're sitting there wanting to get
laid too oh no
who knew
uh I Googled best pickup lines from a
girl's perspective and hit him with this
it's I know it's no nut November
but I'm trying to make you nut
I know it's no nut November but I'm
trying to make you nut oh do people say
Don't eat nuts in November
wait you said that
long story short we've been together for
four years
and have started living together wait a
minute
[Music]
that was your opening line and that
turned into a relationship
that is unfucking believable
if if I did the male version of that to
a woman I'd get slapped in the face
oh God why can't a month start with P
I'm trying to think what I could say the
equivalent of that no titties there's no
tea [__] month
uh somebody knows what it is
there a c month no
there's no a month
ass [__] titties
hey I know it's no sex September but
could you [__] jump on my dick I mean
it's basically that's the male version
Ah that's not a good one um
well congratulations anyway it's the
person she says I never thought it would
end up this way for us but I don't
regret it for the guy who was asking for
the best pickup line just shoot your
shot and have a little confidence you
might miss but you're also you also
might score
wait why are you talking to me like
you're a guy you have a [__] you can
just go out and get laid what is the
[__] problem your opening line could
be hey who wants to [__] this
laughs
I like how you you're really talking to
me like this [__] grizzled vet I like
it all right you might miss but you also
might score so just have fun and you'll
track someone just like you uh nothing
is more attractive than a man with
confidence and a sense of humor that's
how I got my wife I'm not gonna lie to
you
oh my God was she shooting me down
love your [__] love watching you at
Fenway uh wish you the best on your
journey to a healthier life Namaste oh
look at that she's a yogi
I like that person
Yogi with a little Swagger hey shoot
your shot yeah you look confident you
might get you know she did everything
but toss on my bald head
um yeah that's how I ended up with my
wife
she was just shooting me down and
shooting me down
and I remember that oh God what a
[__] night that was and then that
other guy was trying to [__] block me we
ended up at dinner and finally I just
looked at her and I said we at least
split a cab with me and she's trying to
be like just difficult why do you want
to split a cab with me that's what she
said and I said because I want to kiss
you
and then she looked down
and I knew I had her that was it
and every time I tell she goes oh get
out of here it's like I did I did you
looked down that was it
that was it
that was great too and then we got up to
leave and she said okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna split a cab with you and then the
dude who's like [__] blocking me at a
[__] Olympic level
actually said to her she go he goes hey
he said to her he goes hey where do you
live
and she goes I live up uh Harlem 110th
Street he goes oh I live up there you
want to split he said to her do you want
to split a cab
like no one I was trying to [__] bang
her
he said that and then she just goes no
no she goes I'm gonna I'm gonna take a
cab with Bill and he goes oh no but you
know I'm right I'm right on the way and
she just said the guy's name she goes
I'm splitting a cab with Bill and then
we're both staring at him and then he
then he felt stupid oh okay cool you
know
you know whatever
so I never tell you this story so then
we get in the cab
where the [__] were we we're down there
Houston
and the roads were all bumpy
and we're in the cab and there goes I
thought you said you were going to kiss
me
and I said well I'm waiting for a red
light because it's too bumpy
so we stopped at a red light and I
kissed her and he is like the greatest
kisser ever
and I was like wow
and then we started driving again
and then with the car stopped again and
then Nia said it's another red light and
now 20 years later we're still together
see so there you go my little Yogi
Namaste person I got a little game I
threw it out there I threw it out there
and you know what you know throwing it
out there you know that ends up with two
beautiful kids and standing in a two
hour and 40 minute [__] line
waiting on a three minute ride but I do
it again
um all right
pulling up a little short here 55
minutes in
um go to the Moto GP app watch this race
this weekend maybe get into it with me
because I'll be talking about it a lot
this year I'm totally in
um it's going to be in Spain uh you can
watch it online
motogp.com you can get caught up watch
the first three races there are only 20
laps you know what's great too they got
Moto 3 and Moto 2 before it those are
all the up and coming uh Racers and a
lot of times those races can be just as
good if not better than the best one you
get three races
um it's one of the best
um Bargains out there all right that's
it
go [__] yourselves and I'll check in on
you on Thursday